THE GIANTS.
ARE.
HERE!
And Shanks might be too as we got one of the
most BRUTAL.
JAW-DROPPING chapters of the Egghead island
arc.
And WOW, it is INSANE the sheer power on display
by these giants as they wipe ENTIRE SECTIONS
of the marine fleet in a STUNNING SHOW OF
FORCE.
And you can say all you want that these are
just fodder marine ships, but I. DO.
NOT.
CARE!
It is still just so incredible to see such
powerful allies pulling up to help the Straw
Hats in this scenario.
But while we still don’t see Shanks in this
chapter, I don’t want to entirely rule out
the possibility of the Red Haired Emperor
being here quite yet.
Because there are actually a number of reasons
it makes sense for him to arrive at the future
island.
First, we last saw Shanks in chapter 1079
when he completely DEMOLISHED the entire Kid
Pirates in one slash of his sword.
And with that act of violence, we have entered
a new era of Shanks.
No longer is he just sitting around waiting
for things to happen.
Nope, he is ready to claim the One Piece,
so it would make sense that he would be actively
collecting the poneglyphs.
And we already saw him take the copies that
Kid had, and we think he got the final one
from Elbaf, so if he is truly on a rampage
towards Laugh Tale then the next easiest step
would be to come to Egghead and steal the
one missing poneglyph copy he is missing from
the Straw Hats.
So yeah, Evil Shanks is still very much on
the table.
Or, if he’s not here for the Poneglyphs,
there is one other situation that makes just
TOO MUCH SENSE.
Because remember that even if you have the
poneglyphs you still need someone to actually
read them.
And the one person who can do just that is
Nico Robin, who is on Egghead and conveniently
seems to very much be injured and unable to
protect herself.
So just saying, we’ve been waiting for the
Blackbeard pirates to swoop in and kidnap
Robin, but it might be another Emperor doing
just that instead.
And if that wasn’t enough to satisfy your
Shanks fantasy, then also remember that Shanks
has history with the Celestial Dragons and
the Gorosei.
In fact, it is likely that he was born a Celestial
dragon AND we’ve even seen him having secret
conversations with the Five Elders.
So wouldn’t it just make so much sense for
the first time we really get to see a Gorosei’s
powers that we also learn more about their
connection to Shanks?
Shanks could also clash with the Blackbeard
pirates or the Holy Knights if either of them
actually show up in the conflict, but either
way, don’t rule out the option of Shanks
showing up just yet.
But back to the giants because since WE KNOW
they are here now, it’s time to take a deep
dive into what this means for the current
arc and the future of Elbaf.
First let’s break down WHY they are here.
Well, of course remember that in chapter 1066
we learned that Vegapunk studied all of the
research from Ohara that was rescued and moved
to Elbaf.
Of course, Vegapunk seemed to study with the
survivor of Ohara, who is the giant Jaguar
D. Saul, so it would make sense that Saul
would want to rescue Vegapunk if he knew his
friend was in danger.
So we could be seeing Saul very soon if this
is the case.
However, we also see in this chapter that
the two main giants, Dorry and Broggy, proudly
state that they are here for Straw Hat Luffy.
So maybe it wasn’t Saul who sent the giants
at all.
If that’s the case then you need to keep
in mind that this guy is a member of the Straw
Hat Grand Fleet, and has a portion of Luffy’s
vivre card.
So it is entirely possible that after Dorry
and Broggy obliterated the Kid pirate’s
ship, they decided to come find Luffy on their
own.
Regardless of the reason though, the fact
is THEY ARE HERE!
And they’ve already done MASSIVE DAMAGE
by erasing the marine ships surrounding one
part of the island.
Which means, what are they going to do next?
Well, the easy answer is to create an escape
route for the Straw Hats to flee the island.
Remember that in the last chapter, it was
once again explained how the Straw Hats’
original plan to use the VegaForce to get
past the blockade is no longer an option.
So the giants showing up creates a much needed
diversion for the crew to eventually escape
on the Sunny.
However, if you think the giants are just
going to walk up and take out Saturn and Kizaru
then you are dead wrong.
Because as impressive as all the damage looks
in this chapter, we have to remember that
a five year old Big Mom EASILY took out one
of these elder giants who used to be the leaders
of the Giant Pirates.
So in reality, these guys shouldn't really
be even close to Yonko tier, which would be
the minimum required power level in order
to fight Kizaru or Saturn.
That doesn’t mean that Dorry and Broggy
can’t hold off the World Government fighters
though, just don’t expect this to be a sweeping
victory now that the giants are here.
And while we’re talking about their arrival,
did anyone else see Dorry call Luffy “The
Sun God”???
Like, excuse me!???
That honestly was the most shocking thing
to me about this chapter.
Because as far as we know, no one has told
the giants that Luffy is Sun God Nika, so
does that mean that the Sun God is already
a part of the giants’ legends?
If so then that means they could also have
ties to the Buccaneer race which practically
confirms which we’ve long assumed that the
giants were once allies of the Ancient Kingdom
and Joy Boy!
And wow!
I’m just SO excited that pieces are finally
connecting and if the giants DO KNOW lore
about Joy Boy, then we could be learning some
of that VERY SOON.
On top of that, the giants knowing about the
Sun God and possibly Joy Boy just adds another
One Piece race that is connected to those
figures.
We already know the fishmen made some promise
with Joy Boy and the minks live on Zunesha
who even said that Joy Boy had returned.
And Nika is said to be a hero for oppressed
and enslaved people, so all that put together
just makes it all the more likely that all
the races of the world will unite with Luffy
to finally liberate the world.
However, it is also entirely possible that
Shanks told the giants about Luffy's new legendary
status as well, but I'm not too sure why he
would do that at this point.
Now to reel things back in, I want to clarify
that at this point I think an escape is more
likely for the Straw Hats than them straight
up defeating Saturn and Kizaru.
But if that is true then they will likely
travel with the giants for at least some time.
However, as excited as we are for the giants’
arrival it could have SOUL-CRUSHING consequences
for the future of the story.
Because remember, we have been explicitly
told by Oda that he is trying to condense
the story and get to the end.
And if the giants are showing up here when
no one really expected them, then I could
easily imagine a scenario where this is the
only true interaction we have with giants
from Elbaf.
Because listen to this.
Apart from the thrill of adventure, what did
we expect from Elbaf?
An Usopp moment?
Most likely finding the fourth Road Poneglyph?
A reunion between Robin and Saul?
Well, with the giants arriving here, we could
actually get ALL of those things once the
crew escapes from Egghead.
Which would mean there is no real need to
go to Elbaf.
And I’m not saying that’s what I want,
but it is a distinct possibility now that
the giants are here on Egghead.
Let’s assume that isn’t the case though,
and once the battle is over then the Straw
Hats would likely sail back to Elbaf with
an escort of giant longships.
And the question of what happens next would
once again be the most important to discuss.
Does Luffy’s alliance with the Giant Pirates
mean he is allied with all the giants?
Or would the rulers of Elbaf think differently?
And how does Shanks fit into all this?
If he isn’t here on Egghead, will the straw
hats still meet him in Elbaf or will he be
off collecting the other one or two poneglyph
copies that he still needs?
I’m not too sure at this point, but there
is one figure connected to the giants that
we haven’t really discussed yet, and that
is of course Usopp.
Because it seems like Usopp has been connected
with the giants FOREVER and he has even befriended
many giants throughout the story.
However, he has literally done NOTHING for
the entire Egghead arc, so if there was an
Usopp moment that Oda was saving for us, then
the best time for it to come is now that the
giants have arrived.
And that might mean he has some truly heroic
moment or he gives an inspiring speech, but
either way don’t be surprised if Usopp shows
us something special in the final chapters
of Egghead.
As hype as the giants and, potentially Shanks,
arriving is though, there was SO MUCH MORE
that happened this chapter.
Because bodies were dropping left and right.
Vegapunk got stabbed by Saturn!
Franky AND Sanji got blasted by Kizaru!
Then Luffy returned and slammed Kizaru away
from his friends!
Really the battle is heating up, and it seems
like Luffy will end up holding off Kizaru
while the rest of the crew tries to escape.
But that just leaves Saturn, who is still
a MAJOR PROBLEM.
However, we might have actually figured out
how to defeat him because as we all expected,
the Pacifistas are once again on our side.
And sure we didn’t know how it was going
to happen exactly, but I don't know who is
actually surprised by this twist at this point.
In fact, in this chapter Vegapunk revealed
that he originally programmed Bonney as the
highest level of command for the Pacifistas
so she can order them to do whatever she wants,
which completely wipes out Saint Saturn's
commands.
Which obviously the first thing she absolutely
should do is order them to blast Saturn over
and over again until he is dead.
And if you remember one of the ways we thought
you might be able to kill Saturn is to keep
hurting him until he runs out of healing,
and an unstoppable wave of lasers beams seems
like the perfect way to do that.
Which could ultimately lead to Saturn’s
death, which would be so, so sweet at this
point.
Or if he isn't dead, then he could also somehow
teleport to protect himself.
I could imagine him doing something similar
to the way he arrived on the island, with
this dark magic circle.
Although, we don’t know exactly how that
works so who knows if that is even possible.
It does leave a few interesting questions
for the future though, such as will Bonney
be able to control the Pacifistas forever?
If so, that is a major boost to her powers
because these things are so hard to kill.
And if Vegapunk made Bonney the ultimate authority
for the Pacifista, does that mean he did the
same for the Seraphim?
That one I kinda doubt, since the reason he
gave her command of the Pacifistas was that
he didn’t want Bonney to be hurt by something
that looks like her father, but it’s still
possible.
Though why didn't Vegapunk just reveal this
earlier and save everyone the trouble of fighting
the Pacifistas in the first place???
I don't know???
But speaking on Bonney’s powers, this chapter
also showed Bonney learning that Luffy is
the real Nika.
Now remember that just a few chapters ago,
we were shown that Bonney’s powers are fueled
by WHAT SHE BELIEVES is possible.
And when she was about to be killed by Saturn,
she lost faith which basically drained her
powers.
Now that she’s seen Luffy though, I do wonder
if her powers will be restored or even increased
because of her renewed faith in Nika.
And if that’s the case, what kind of amazing
things could she do with her powers?
For example, could she make a future where
her father is still alive?
I’m not sure at this point, but anything
certainly seems possible.
As does Bonney’s case to become the next
Straw Hat.
And I know this has been discussed many times
during the Egghead Island arc, but this kind
of moment with Bonney we saw on the epic double
page spread is exactly the type that makes
me think a person could join the crew.
It honestly reminds me of Nami’s moment
in Arlong Park and Robin’s in Enies Lobby.
To take this even further though, we now have
even more evidence that she fits the normal
straw hat criteria.
First, Bonney already has a dark backstory.
Second, she is clearly being freed by Luffy
and is going through her own character journey
during this arc.
And finally, if she does travel with the Straw
Hats, she has a dream of finding out more
about her father’s Buccaneer culture and
beliefs.
So bam, there you have it.
Literally the perfect Straw Hat candidate,
and since she is still technically a child,
she could be a cabin girl.
Or if we want to lean into the religious aspect,
she could be the ship’s priest or something
along those lines.
Besides that though, there is one thing that
is pretty easy to miss in all the chaos and
battles happening on the island.
And that’s the fact that we also got the
first hint of movement from the Iron Giant
ever since it first awoke during chapter 1092.
Which it just seems like Oda is really hammering
in the idea that the giant responds to Luffy
using his Gear 5 powers.
I mean, that is also what caused it to wake
up during that prior chapter and now that
Luffy is back to fighting with Gear 5, the
Iron Giant is moving again.
Still so excited to see what is going to happen
next with this piece of ancient technology.
Also, can we just appreciate Luffy casually
turning the ground into rubber to catch his
falling friends?
Like, this was a power we thought might be
his true and ONLY awakening power, so to see
it just be one small part of his actual awakening
is pretty awesome if you ask me.
And if you are like me and sometimes forget
that Luffy’s Gear 5 powers are more than
just cartoon wacky abilities, then check out
this video where I fully explain ALL OF Luffy’s
INSANE Awakened abilities [Gear 5 Explained
video].
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.